you're not going to believe this because
it sounds crazy
but it's true we don't know the reason
why we don't know if it was an accident
or if it was deliberate but the
Mar-A-Lago surveillance footage room
from which important surveillance
footage related to Donald Trump's
handling of classified documents that he
stole
has been flooded because a trump
employee at Mar-A-Lago drained the pool
into the surveillance room
it sounds unbelievable best Levin has a
piece in Vanity Fair about it called
we're sure there's a totally innocent
reason the Mar-A-Lago surveillance
footage room flooded amidst the doj's
Trump investigation here's a report from
CNN explaining what happened listen to
how insane this is and what I am earning
and have
earned uh
firing about is that there was a flood
at Mar-A-Lago back October specifically
one of the men a maintenance worker who
was captured on some of this video
surveillance tape helping to move some
of the boxes in and out of that storage
room he drained the pool at Mar-A-Lago
in October and when that happened it
flooded a room and that room had I.T
equipment in it that had surveillance
footage and so we don't know
guys it's
uh can you believe this uh and it's not
clear if prosecutors believe that this
flood was intentional it
uh it's stake right but it is one of
these things
of things that just are suspicious to
prosecutors have raised questions yeah
and we do know too that prosecutors have
received some testimony and some answers
about what happened there and some of
the testimony is that the video
surveillance system wasn't damaged in
this flood but all of these questions
are going back to did Donald Trump give
some sort of direction or did these
people who were working for him this
maintenance worker and another man who
was captured on tape moving boxes well
not his body man were they taking steps
to inquire about the surveillance
footage or want to sort of all right you
you get it okay so at this point we
certainly can't say Trump ordered anyone
Hey listen how about this drain the pool
into the surveillance room and let's
damage all of the equipment so they
can't get the footage in fact there was
that one assertion made in this report
that that was not actually the cause of
the surveillance footage going missing
it went missing for whatever reason we
still don't know but apparently summer
claiming that it was not a result of the
pool being drained into the surveillance
room but it certainly doesn't sound good
there's a very good uh tweet thread from
Brian Allen who says an employee at
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago residence
drained the Resort's swimming pool last
October and ended up flooding a room
where computer servers containing
surveillance video logs were kept
sources familiar with the matter told
CNN while it is unclear if the room was
intentionally flooded or if it happened
by mistake the incident occurred amid a
series of events that Federal
prosecutors found suspicious that's the
understatement of the century at least
one witness has been asked by
prosecutors about the flooded server
room as part of the federal
investigation into Trump's handling of
classified documents according to one of
the sources the incident which has not
been previously reported came roughly
two months after the FBI retrieved
hundreds of classified documents from
Florida residents and as prosecutors
obtained surveillance footage to track
how White House records were moved
around the resort prosecutors have been
examining any effort to obstruct the
Justice Department's investigation after
Trump received a subpoena in May 22 for
classified documents so listen I I want
to be really upfront with everybody at
this point we cannot say that this was a
deliberate act or that it was ordered by
Donald Trump you know sometimes in
situations with multiple levels of
people involved they will keep the boss
isolated for plausible deniability and
so it could have been someone else who
said listen we're not even going to tell
Trump we're doing this but just drain
the pool into the surveillance room and
blah blah blah blah we we just it's all
speculation right now
but it just has guilt dripping all over
it and there are those who will say
David this is just too much of a
coincidence it's too much of a
coincidence that in the immediate period
where Donald Trump clearly lied about
what he did with the documents so then
investigators said all right well you've
got security cameras let's get a look at
the footage they slow walk providing the
footage and in the meantime the server
room floods although again in their
defense they're saying that's not the
reason why we can't get you the
surveillance footage it always stinks to
high heaven it's yet another one of
these incredible coincidences but we
can't say for sure that it was
deliberate and maybe it wasn't maybe it
was just incompetence I mean let's let's
be very honest
Trump ran on I will hire the best people
and then he hired terrible people and
when it blows up in his face he says
well they lied to me to get hired or
whatever the case may be we know bottom
line we know Trump doesn't hire the best
people and maybe that applies to the
same person who was both in charge of
the pool and moving the documents I
don't know I don't know why the same
person would be involved in both of
those things it's all extraordinarily
weird I want to hear from you
does this seem suspicious or is it
probably nothing let me know in a
YouTube comment in an email in a tweet
wherever and make sure of course that
you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel folks we're pushing to 2 million
subscribers and I would love for you to
be one of the two million I've mentioned
this before I will mention it again last
month we just got very strong numbers
for May on the YouTube channel this is
pretty interesting from a data
perspective in May almost 4 million
different people watched video clips on
YouTube almost 4 million like 3.8
million
but we have only 1.7 million YouTube
subscribers what this means is that
there are 2.1 million people out there
who watched Clips but didn't subscribe
remember you don't have to get notified
of every video just because you've
subscribed but it really helps us direct
the YouTube algorithm to direct people
to us when you do hit that subscribe
button so please do it let's go to 2
million let's take a very quick break
and then we're going to continue Chris
Christie folks I have good things to say
about Republican Chris Christie he had a
very strong Town Hall last night after
this short break one of our sponsors
today is Bon charge I have always
enjoyed dry saunas you get in there your
heart rate is up dilates the blood
vessels can soothe achy joints and
muscles it's relaxing it's just a great
way to remove a little stress but one
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below